ever since I first laid eyes on the
lands between I couldn't shake a certain
feeling this world has clearly seen
better days most areas and major
landmarks are in complete ruin which
gives us a sense that these places in
times past were incredible
representations of their respective
cultures and what they believed in
however I have never been able to shake
the feeling that some of these areas the
people and creatures that inhabit them
and the Landscapes surrounding them
gives off this vibe that they simply
don't belong here obviously I haven't
been able to explain this feeling or I
would have made a video on it a long
time ago but I received a theory from
one of our community Discord members
pixel perspective that has finally
started to put into perspective this
uneasy feeling that the lands between
are not just in ruin but completely
broken in more ways than one before we
start be sure to understand that this is
just a theory to start conversations and
debate within the community as we have
done on this channel since the game
first came out obviously a DLC could
release and completely discredit every
theory that has been made here and that
is the beauty and mystery of this game
that keeps me coming back for more so
respect each other and discuss what you
think in the comments make sure to
subscribe like the video all the good
YouTube stuff to help out the channel
and with all that said let's get started
I have long observed the lands between
this world is in dire need of repair and
death
indiscriminate
I believe this moment with Melina is one
of the most important pieces of dialogue
in the entire game it's the culmination
of all of the hard work it took for us
to reach this new height literally it is
the highest point in the lands between
and allows us to look down and observe
the world we just traveled and struggled
through to reach this moment and through
all of it Melina was with us she's what
started it all for us and we'd likely be
wandering the lands between with no
purpose if it wasn't for her offering us
an accord to help her reach the ERD tree
and in return she would play the role as
finger Maiden to turn the runes we find
into strength to Aid us in our search
for the Eldon ring but as we can see the
lands between is in complete disarray
and it's likely been this way or a very
long time
if we return to Kali in the Church of
Ella after speaking with melna at the
gate front to Stormville Castle we can
find who he later come to know as Ronnie
waiting for us he casts a spell that
puts kale and his donkey to sleep and
then beckons us over to have a short
word with her
this way tarnished may I have a word now
Ronnie first introduces herself as Rena
during this first interaction which is
obviously strange however it seems like
many people don't put much thought into
this notion but little things like this
are vitally important in Elden Ring's
story these types of details tend to
bother me in a way that makes me try
even harder to understand its purpose
and intention within the overall Story
the name Rena is mentioned elsewhere in
the game a tower adjacent to Ronnie's
home is called Rena's rise what is even
more interesting is that the area that
these towers occupy is called the three
sisters there's Ronnie's rise Runners
rise and sullivas's Rise however it's
pretty clear that celavis has just
recently occupied this Tower during this
time working under Ronnie and is of no
relation to Ronnie herself meaning he
isn't likely to be considered one of the
three sisters so this brings up the
question who is the third sister now
this is where the theory starts to get
interesting so bear with me here it
seems fairly obvious that the second
Roundtable hold we find in leandel is in
the present timeline and the round table
that Melina brings us to is in the past
in Landell the round table is identical
to where Melina takes us but is
obviously dilapidated the biggest source
of proof to this theory is the
description of the coded sword which is
found upon the throne of the two fingers
in the Landell version of the Round
Table hold which reads as hidden sword
once granted to the tarnished of the
round table by the two fingers a
formless cipher comprises its blade
which deals holy damage that no Shield
can repel Champions would gather at the
round table hold in days long past when
the two fingers were masters of oration
their flesh Yet full of vigor the fact
that the lore of the weapon meant that
it is a cipher which is usually
considered a key to unlocking a puzzle
shows us that it is a significant clue
in understanding The Round Table's
history along with this the cipher Pata
can be found in the main Roundtable hold
which description reads the same as the
coded sword but in addition says the
furtive inscription appears to hang in
the air the language of light spoken by
the two fingers now along with all this
information here is the main Theory the
events of the shattering actually
fragmented reality itself making
different times as well as different
realities but lied into itself I believe
some characters are aware of this
phenomenon but most are not it's not a
secret that many believe that Ronnie the
witch could potentially be Melina and
time travel would highly support this
since Ronnie's real body can be found at
the top of the car in the Tower and has
been long dead Melina could be the
younger version of Ronnie and there's a
few things that support this Theory the
first is obviously Ronnie's ghostly
figure that shares the same closed eye
as Melina and the symbol underneath her
eye has similarities to that ghostly
figure next is the similar fashion of
when Ronnie and melna disappear it's
really hard not to see the similarities
of the blue aura when they do this it's
a small detail but very important
nonetheless finally they both seem to be
the only characters in the game that
acknowledge or even know of torrent
torrent has chosen you treat him with
respect
I shall leave this for thee and at the
behest of Torrance former Master take it
should thou overcome thy suspicion this
theory is suggesting that while certain
people may be different in our current
version of the lands between they may
have been the same in an alternate
timeline or Dimension it's like when an
NPC invades your current world they do
so from another world or reality
entirely but is all composed of the same
pieces the archery and minor archeries
act as conduits to be the link between
these worlds which would explain why
when you kill an earth tree Avatar
certain NPC Invaders can no longer
invade your world this could be similar
to when Melena tells us that when we
reach Landell she can freely move on her
own she has a better connection with the
archery and is stronger because of it
when the earth tree is set Ablaze the
link is weakened causing the fire the
seep into the time Rift which results in
the past version of the Round Table hold
to burn down and eventually leads to its
current state that you find in Landell
another thought that we should mention
is Melina's hands Melina has scar tissue
on her hands which could mean she has
been the burning maiden or the one who
sets the herd tree Ablaze before in
previous ages or realities she keeps
trying to fix this broken timeline in
every age or alternate reality with all
that said If This Were true then Ronnie
and Melina and freely move through time
from Ronnie's dialogue we can surmise
that she wants to change something about
the past in Ronnie's rise she tells us
this I stole death long ago I'll search
now for the dark path that I might one
day upend the whole of it
and rid the world of all that came
before the context of this remark can be
taken pretty literally she wants to
reverse something something that came
before her miniature doll form also
tells us this
and EG both
aren't willing to give too much to me
yet they both understand
what lieth beyond the dark path but I
must betray everything
and read the world of what came before
this is in the same context as the last
but now she is remarking as if to rid
the world of the actual event entirely
now come at the age of the Stars
a Thousand-Year Voyage under the wisdom
of the Moon as I've said in previous
videos I believe this Moon we see during
Ronnie's ending is actually a portal or
time gate that will bring you back 1 000
years into the past allowing her to try
to change the past with the knowledge
she now has of events leading up to the
current state of the world one thing
that Ronnie says that seems to bridge a
gap in the Ronnie ismelona theory is
when she says this I am certain now
fate steered us to our first encounter I
must thank torrent too for his part this
reminds me of some dialogue after our
fight with margin when Melania reveals
that she has been testing us stating
that torrent had our measure from the
very start forgive me
I've been testing you to determine if
the Elden ring would truly have you if
you had the metal to endure this long
and arduous path it seems my worries
were unfounded torrent had your measure
from the very start whereas I merely
pretended now we know that Ronnie
initiated the night of black knives and
she states that it was her choice to
eliminate her corporeal flesh but she
never really States why here's what this
theory is also suggesting Ronnie and
Rena are two forms of the same being
just as America and radagon are and the
Rena Persona is destined to become the
glomide queen just as we see at the end
of the frenzied flame ending this is not
too hard to believe since Ronnie is the
daughter of radagon so there is a
potential that there could be a birth
trait of creating two forms of the same
being could be passed down to their
children the family probably decided to
present Ronnie and Rena as sisters who
hide the fact that they were the same
being just as it was a well-kept secret
between America and radagon the name
Rena would fit well as the daughter of
ranala as similar names befit the
demigod Offspring throughout the entire
game so perhaps Ronnie plotted the
Knight of black knives to destroy that
side of herself after being warned by a
future version of herself meaning that
Ronnie in her doll form rattled to the
past to find her younger self and warn
her that her other persona Rena is
destined to become the glomide queen and
perform great atrocities after seeing it
herself in an alternate age or reality
she teaches her past self all she knows
in cold sorceries and that eventually he
has to die
but it's not as simple as this her
future self knows that her own actions
have absolutely destroyed the lands
between so she helps her young self
permanently close her left eye with a
magical seal in an attempt to keep the
Rena Persona at Bay and sends her off
into the future to try and find the
tarnished of Legend to help her fix all
of the collateral damage of the
shattering that was of course caused by
her actions during the night of black
knives but what Ronnie does not realize
is that the glomide queen is actually
created as a result of sending herself
into the future into the current
Dimension and timeline when we play the
game in one of the alternate realities
we chose to become the Lord of frenzied
flame burning everything including
whatever power holds that seal on the
eye of Melina and Ronnie which causes
the seal
to fade and allow her eye to open
because of this the Rena Persona awakens
and becomes the glom eyed Queen swearing
to follow you to the ends of time and
deliver you what is yours
destined death he travels back in time
to commit the atrocities that she was
trying to prevent in the first place
creating one giant time Paradox the
three sisters are the three
personalities or personas of the same
being Ronnie Rena and Melina
so how many of you chose the Lord of
frenzied flame ending during your
playthrough how many of you chose to
help Ronnie travel thousands of years
into the past to fix what she had
started herself each and every one of us
who has played the game is a tarnished
but all of us are different all of us
choosing different paths different
appearances different builds and
ultimately choosing different endings
each one of us is an alternate dimension
of the same whole of the same mix of
timelines and realities that were once
separated by the Elden ring itself until
it was shattered now the lands between
is quite literally between realities
between Dimensions everything has now
collided into one another the past the
present and the future are now one in
the same as time itself has been broken
what I'd like to leave with you all
today is what I believe the upcoming DLC
will focus on there are two great rooms
that we have yet to find Ronnie's
discarded great Rune and Nicola's great
room each great room seems to have a
trait associated with the demigod Shard
Bearer itself I'd like to make a
complete video on this but just as an
example melania's great Rune allows The
Shard Bearer to harshly heal after
attacking an opponent I believe that
Melania needed to battle opponents in
order to stay alive the Scarlet raw
eating away at her could be subsided for
a while after taking the blood of her
opponents the use of unalloid gold
created by her twin brother mikola along
with her great Rune could keep her from
dying as long as she continues to battle
against opponents and heals herself from
that battle Melania and her great room
are connected in this way so what could
nikola's great Rune do I believe that
Michel is great Rune has to do with time
itself as we know Nikola is cursed with
eternal Youth and while this may seem
like a good thing it's obvious through
Nicholas actions that he was trying to
grow into something more than he was
before whether that was for himself or
for his sister Melania though it could
be possible that nikola's Eternal youth
comes from the traits bestowed on him by
his great room each great Rune connected
together forms the Eldon ring and when
it was shattered Nikola held the key to
time itself and could potentially use it
to bend time and rid himself of the
curse of Eternal youth we still have to
learn a lot more about pretty much
everything in this entire game to make
any sense of all of this but it is so
much fun to discuss these theories that
maybe Elden ring doesn't even need a
deal
I really hope you guys enjoyed this
video make sure to join the Discord to
discuss even further with the community
and the creator of this Theory pixel
perspective I absolutely love this
Theory and I'd like to thank him for
allowing me to create a video on the
topic I have a strange feeling that
Elden ring DLC is just around the corner
honestly I'm between that and believing
that Elden ring will never have a DLC
but like I said I'll be making a video
on that shortly thanks again for
watching and I will see you all in the
next video take care